this is a production of Cornell
University
on Necker Dennis Bergen not revolution
class he went to the hometown campus
going to vary on nipple action graduated
in December he keeps apologizing for not
having all this data for accuracy that's
a very impressive data that we already
got in great experimental filming after
graduation next consent many times to
work until the August where I'll start a
ph.d program utilizing small pockets
mark illogical annotations the climate
change in corporate school Jesus the
Latin name in there alright everybody my
name is Nick and this is the project
I've been working on for about the past
year now and as Mike said I'm going to
continue to work on it over the summer
and in the next semester and it's part
of my honors thesis here and I've been
working on with with Kevin Nixon so as
Mike mentioned I and still in the
process of continuing on this project so
this is basically just a status update
of where I am and where I plan to be in
the next year and as a quick outline
today I'm going to talk about just an
introduction and the goals of the
project so what we're trying to do and
how we plan to do that and then some of
the methods that we're going to and that
we have been using over the last year
and how those methods are aligning with
some of the methods I've been used in
the past and maybe some new things as
well that haven't been used and then
also mentioned some of the results that
we expect to get and some of the future
work over the summer and the next
semester so as an introduction it's
important to note that there's been a
really strong correlation between leaf
shape and climate for several several
decades ecologists and botanists have
noticed that weeds that are for example
thin and highly dissected or highly
tooth's have highly toothed margins are
more often found in the northern more
temperate regions of the United States
or of the world and leaves that are
thicker and with entire margins are
often found in wetter
more tropical climates and also leaves
they're much smaller thicker and maybe
you're more spiny
are found in dry climates and desert
desert habitat
and these correlate is a lot there are
several hypotheses that can tell us why
weaves are shaped this way and the
correlations that that go along with
climate in the morphological variation
but a lot of the previous work is just
focused on these general characteristics
of leaves they've looked at leaf shape
and maybe deciduous versus evergreen
characteristics but this project in this
project we plan to look at some
characteristics that are going to be a
little bit more specific and maybe tell
us a little bit more about the
adaptations that leaves have the climate
and maybe allow us to make some
hypotheses about why leaves are shaped
the way they are so the inspiration for
this project came from a pretty simple
question and that's why our oak leaf
shaped so differently if you guys have
any experience with oak taxonomy or oak
morphology then you've noticed that
there's a huge variation and the shape
of their leaves the habitats they occupy
and and their lifestyle as well so we
wanted to try to answer that question
and in doing that we hope to achieve a
few goals and the first goal is to
determine the leaf characteristics and
oak leaves that are most adapted to
certain climates we want to make some
really specific and precise measurements
to be able to make hypotheses about why
leaves are shaped the way they are and
hopefully correlate that to the specific
climates they occupy and we can also
develop methods that can be used for
other more fug other morphological
studies and other taxa so we're going to
do a lot of digital morphological
measurements that can hopefully be not
only used for Oaks but maybe other taxon
the future and then can also be applied
to things like niche modeling or
taxonomic purposes so that we can better
understand how morphology relates to
adaptation and and habitat preference
and then we can also use these
correlations that we that we find to
improve our predictions about paleo
climate so for example if we know that
the flora of a certain area has leaf
characteristics of a certain of a
certain type and we can look at a fossil
flora and make correlations between the
leaves that we see today and the climate
say inhabit and the Paleo climate
of that of the time when that one of
those fossil flora so why do we choose
Oaks well they've got a really immense
and diverse morphological geographical
and and habitat preference as I
mentioned before they are extremely
diverse there's over 400 species of Oaks
and they range from enormous deciduous
trees to evergreen rhizomatous shrubs
and they have habitats ranging from the
northern temperate climates into the end
of the subtropics and tropics and their
weak morphology is equally as variable
so looking at very different leaf size
from some of the extremes here over to
some of the smaller leaves here leaf
shape there's lobed margins you see
entire margins you see deeper lobes
margins with many spines and the
variation is really a minced that you
see see in Oaks and it's it's no
surprise that they also have a really
broad geographical distribution so
you'll see them from southern Canada all
the way into the subtropics and tropics
of northern South America and also from
coast to coast in the United States and
this is this all is also a testament to
the diversity of habitats that they
occupy so you'll find them in temperate
cooler regions in the North drier
regions in the southwest and wet even
cloud forest regions in the sub tropics
and tropical tropical locations so based
on their diverse morphology their
geographic wide geographical
distribution and their really broad
habitat ability to edit adapt to
different habitats they make an ideal
group to study these correlations
between morphology and climate and in
addition to that we also happen to have
not wanting to go there yeah yeah in
addition to that we also happen to have
the largest collection of Oaks in the
world at the at the herbarium here at
Cornell we have we have a collection of
over 230 oak species and over 13,000
data-based accessions of oak specimens
so this really makes it for an ideal
group to study to to look on this
project so on to some of the methods in
how I plan to look for these
correlations and measure these these
differences we can do a lot of the work
that I've been talking about with
basically just herbarium specimens and
using in a very impression we can take a
look at the label and get collection
information on where that session was
look collected and we can pinpoint that
on a map with a latitude and longitude
coordinate and once we have latitude and
longitude coordinates for the entire
species or for the entire for the entire
species of our collection then we can
map those map all of the species onto a
map and produce a range map of that
species and then we can take the
specific coordinate for the species of
it or the specimen of interest and we
can look at the specific climatic
conditions that that specimen was was in
when it was collected and we can go back
to the original specimen and take take a
look at the take a look at the leaf
characteristics and make make some
really detailed and precise
morphological measurements and putting
all these things together then we're
able to take geography climate and
morphology and put that into one
framework that we can be able to use for
comparisons and to be able to make
hypotheses about how these leaves are
adapting and surviving in these
different habitats so to go into a
little bit more detail to do the geo
referencing we're using a software
called geo locate that was produced by
Tulane University and this is a like I
said just taking information right off
that are barium label and typing that
right into this software interface in
the Geo locate software and usually you
can get a pretty accurate estimation of
where that specimen was collected for
example this one says I don't know if
you can
read about it San Bernardino National
Forest near route 38 and the point comes
really near near to that string that you
typed in and it prints out a latitude
longitude coordinate for you to
automatically apply to that specimen but
it's not this was not always the case
there's always going to be some
uncertainty with your with the
collection information on the label for
example sometimes the collector will
write 10 miles west of Sedona and with
that you don't have much much precision
and you've got to make a pretty broad
estimation about where that specimen was
located and in addition to our
collection in the herbarium we can also
use G Biff which is a global
biodiversity information facility and
this is a database and online database
of nearly 2 million species and I think
over 700 million individual specimens
that have been geo-referenced and
database in a similar way is this so we
can mine that data and be able to
compare that to the data that we're
collecting in the herbarium and also to
field studies that will that I'll be
doing in the summer and to eliminate the
uncertainty with some of the geo
referencing the best way to do that is
to go and make field collections with
precise geographical coordinates and and
better collection information on the
specimen so that's that it's going to be
done this summer and to access climate
data we're going to be using world climb
which is a global which is a world
largest global climate database and it
contains over 40,000 weather stations
across the world
each of these red dots on the map
represents a individual weather station
and this database produces an
interpolated continuous grid of climate
data such that you can input any
latitude longitude coordinate and get a
unique climate profile for that latitude
longitude coordinate and there's a
variety of climatic variables that will
that are presented in this database
including variables on precipitation
temperature and several other different
variables as well and to do
morphological measurements were going to
be using the online herbarium database
that we that we have access to and this
is just an example of what the page
looks like and this is several different
specimens of one specific species and
you can go ahead and choose one
species and embedded right into this
into the herbarium database website we
have implemented a system of
morphological measurements so that we
can write on it right on the database be
able to measure things like petiole
length
leaf length leaf width distance to the
widest point perimeter of the leaf
surface area of the leaf and even you
can count the number of primary and
secondary veins you can measure vein
angle and you can count and measure the
depth and degree of spining and lo being
on all the leaves so this is really
going to make the morphological
measurement process extremely efficient
and quick and not only that it's going
to allow us to have sort of a digital
paper trail of every single measurement
that we make such that every measurement
will be instantly updated and correlated
to that specimen and lock to it and if
we need to go back and modify
measurement to review the measurements
that we made we can always do that
because this measurement system is
embedded in the herbarium database and
we'll be able to have that all connected
and correlated at all time so this is a
big jump or a big change from the
previous ways of just measuring leaves
without with a ruler or with with some
with old instrumentation so once once we
collect a lot of the data then we'll
have a large matrix that includes
several different species these are the
ones I've been working with recently and
they're mostly Western Oaks the numbers
beside them indicate the number of
specimens we have data based and imaged
in the herbarium right now and then as I
mentioned we'll have several different
morphological characteristics that we'll
measure as well and a host of climatic
variables that will be correlated to
each individual specimen and then we can
go ahead and make some attempt to make
correlations and do some analyses
between the different species which
we'll look at some of the different
adaptations and some of the different
characteristics of these species that
are allowing them to adapt and occupy
different habitats and we can also look
at variation within species that will
maybe tell us something about phenotypic
plasticity and some of the variation
that we see in individual plants and
then we can take the whole matrix and
look at very
in across space and time so looking at
how these things vary with geography and
over time as well because we have a
collection that ranges in the herbarium
of over 150 years of collections of
specimens so being able to do all these
will hopefully lead to some conclusions
that will support our hypotheses and the
expected results that we hope to see
here definitely we want to see some some
type of correlation between morphology
and climate and there's been a lot of
like I mentioned a lot of correlations
in the past that have made between low
being and to thing of leaves and we hope
to make come up with something that's a
little bit more specific and maybe a
little bit more applicable to oksu and
then we also hope to hope to improve the
phylogenetic and taxonomic resolution of
Oaks the phylogeny of Oaks is
notoriously unresolved and very
difficult to interpret because of a
large degree of phenotypic plasticity
and hybridization was in the genus so
being able to make these precise and
efficient morphological measurements may
improve the the phylogeny and taxonomy
of the group and we also hope to maybe
improve niche modeling methods and Mitch
modeling in the past is basically just
just used geographic distributions of
species to estimate the ranges of where
those species habitats are but if we can
implement morphological characteristics
that correlate with climate into those
niche models we may be able to better
understand why and how some species
adapt to certain certain regions and in
the future a big portion of this summer
is going to be devoted to a plant
collecting trip across the southwestern
US into California and up into the
northwest to document collect and
photograph several different oak species
to not only make comparisons to some of
the geo referencing and the already
collected specimens that we have but
also to improve the data set and add to
the herbarium collection that we have
here and in doing that I'm going to use
this
because a prototype planetpress that I
hope to help out with the collections
and I'm calling it the plexi press so
it's just basically two sheets of
plexiglass that you can carry in the
field it'll be light and easy and it
will allow imaging and it'll be able to
be scaled and then those can be uploaded
to the herbarium website and
measurements can be made throughout the
summer and in addition to that we can
also hopefully improve the morphological
measurement interface so that we can
make make better and more precise
measurements as we go on so to wrap up
I've got to have a big thanks to Kevin
Dixon who is my research advisor who
supported me a lot throughout this this
project also to Anna and Peter in the
herbarium they've been a huge help
throughout the whole whole process and
also to the plant science committee
Elena
Chris and Mike for helping out with
presentation and advice and to
undergraduate research grants that are
going to support the summer yeah so they
definitely co-occur in this area but
they may have a ranges that differ so
you may find that chestnut oak has a
range that's not the same as a white oak
or a red oak so if we can use
collections from across that range and
be able to correlate those
characteristics to different areas and
we can maybe come up with better
hypotheses about why they have the
shapes they do yes a long one
yeah the phenotypic plasticity is huge
how does that would it be better to look
at the plasticity three positions axis
rather than thousands of marbles I'm
Valerie yes overlapping ranges but since
in genetics consolidation different
morphology rather than a lot yeah
absolutely so that's something that I
think it's possible with this project so
the fact that we're going to have so
many samples such a large sample size
for each species allow us to do that
within species comparison and among
species comparison yep
I'd say yes and especially so with Oaks
even even more so with Oaks you can look
on on one oak branch and see leaves that
have really distinct morphologies and in
the field of summer that's going to be
hopefully avoided by making collections
that are standard with with methodology
as standard along each each specimen and
individual yep yeah absolutely I think
that's maybe the ultimate goal is to get
everything automated just so you can
take a picture of a leaf or take a
picture of a thousand leaves and put
them through an automated system to come
up with all these morphological
characteristics and I think that yeah
that would be the ultimate goal but for
now it's just done by hand
mm-hmm yeah this has been a production
of Cornell University on the web at
Cornell edu